Aaron Sorkin's latest film Molly's game
tells the autobiographical tale of Molly
bloom the so called poker princess that
run underground poker tournaments
attracting all types of individuals from
Hollywood's rich and famous to the
Russian mob unsurprisingly the movie
sticks very close to reality and Sorkin
even went so far as consulting bloom
throughout the screenwriting process one
of the most intriguing aspects of the
film is the identity of player X while
it's never specifically named in the
film there are several possibilities as
to who it could be
on the surface player acts as a
high-profile Hollywood actor who does
his best to derail Molly's game and
shuns her for not acting upon his sexual
advances one of the boldest most
infuriating villains of the air a
babyface young movie star who belittles
Jessica Chastain's and hero Molly bloom
at every turn he takes pride in
destroying lives and eventually put an
end to blooms high-stake poker
enterprise forcing her to up sticks and
regroup on the other side of the country
whilst within Molly's book actors such
as Leonardo DiCaprio Matt Damon and Ben
Affleck are heavily mentioned many have
taken the inspiration behind the
antagonist to be Tobey Maguire in her
memoir McGuire's name comes up a lot and
not always in the nicest way he was an
avid player and responsible for bringing
certain players to the table originally
run by Molly's former boss nicknamed
Dean Keith the movie also implies that
player X had a lot of the power and
brought heavy hitters in and that when
Molly takes over the game is his
approval that she needs to successfully
pull off the coup in Molly's book she
claims that McGuire was integral to the
setting up of her table and even lent
her his own personal card shuffling
machine to speed up hands this DL wasn't
included in the movie or the fact that
he allegedly asked her to bark like a
seal in order to get a thousand-dollar
chip Maguire was even nicknamed Hannibal
Lecter by Molly due to his persona at
the table the film also showcases that
Molly's game was stolen by player X
something the real Molly accused Maguire
of on the page Blum claims that the
actors started getting upset about the
money she was making from tips so ended
up telling his celeb pals to host their
game instead in the film player X steals
her game
he calls him out for running another
player at her table and potentially
ruining its integrity you're so [ __ ]
he tells her over the phone while she's
on her way to an empty hotel room that
should have hosted her weekly game Aaron
Sorkin says that player axes inches one
person he is an amalgamation of several
celebrities who Molly wrote about
however there seems to be another nod to
it being Toby one of the insults Molly
directs her player X is calling him a
green-screen [ __ ] and we all know how
much McGuire was familiar with this when
he played spider-man Maguire has yet to
comment publicly about Molly's game
thanks very much for taking the time to
check out my video on Molly's game I
thought the film was really well acted
and directed and definitely recommend
that you go and check it out at the
cinema if you've already seen it let me
know what you thought of the film and
also who you think player s is based on
you can check out more of my film
theories at definition car at UK which
is linked in the description and make
sure you subscribe my channel to check
out all of my popular culture analysis
thanks again take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]